leave it to disney to poopoo their own
logo reading young Jeremy did the st.
depending on what exactly you mean by
frets the first few pages of this
opening reading show classic moments
where Christopher Robin helped who and
his friends out of a jam conspicuously
absent a time where he helped them learn
how to spell you think I'd be impressed
that they can even write at all but
sorry close doesn't count also does
anyone watching this actually need this
animated storybook reset of Winnie the
Pooh pretty sure we are all well-versed
in the broad particulars of the silly
old bear oh come on this kid didn't hear
yours poem was way over here when a or
got to the end of the poem I didn't
think I need any help remembering the
wood you wouldn't think so would you I
mean it would be one thing if it was an
experience for him when he was four or
five but he's a full-on tweenager right
here if he really had these experiences
at this age there was no possible way he
would convince himself that they were
all part of his imagination despite what
this bit of foreshadowing is trying to
tell us swim people call out what are
you going to do Christopher Robin and
you say nothing and then you go ahead
and do it
suddenly I imagine that in the scenario
Christopher Robin is describing the
people who are calling out are living in
Puerto Rico during a hurricane or
California during a forest fire or Flint
Michigan at a water fountain I'm not
going to do nothing anymore they don't
let you at the boarding school is this
the sequel to where the wild things are
pretty clear Christopher Robin is Mac
and he's been imagining these animals
the whole time to get away from his
trouble family life I don't know if
that's a sin really but I'm gonna count
it as one they aren't even going in with
him I mean even if you don't have the
common decency to make sure the kid gets
settled in there's this boarding school
for God's sake don't you at least have
some papers to sign or something cricket
man I'll have poking the bear when I'm
sinning the Pooh wait a minute now in
the hell did Christopher Robin's score
agent Carter sure he offered his seat on
the bus and then some cheeky blighter
stolen and she kind of laughed at but
did they get into an interesting
conversation on that bus afterwards you
know how Ted took eight years to explain
to his kids how he met their mother this
is like the total opposite of that to
recap Christopher Robin left his
imaginary childhood friends behind he
was terrible at math his dad died he met
Haley out well who is perpetually stuck
in World War two
got her pregnant went to war came home
and met his daughter went to work at
Winslow industry and now he's an asshole
that's like a three-hour movie in 12
minutes of opening credits you much
rather be here than in my stuffy office
for the boring stuff happen in fact
we're the boring stuff happens was
the working title for this movie he's
saying windy tent that's an apple
character incorrectly reads lips speaks
a language interprets a language for
humorous effect cliche we need to
produce the cuts by then it's singles
women but I promised my wife and
daughter I'd take them away this weekend
sir you know what would really solve
this problem Winnie the Pooh so
Christopher Robin has to decide who to
fire and apparently we're going with the
morose Dickensian version of Winnie the
Pooh just like we hoped for and all
adaptations of our fond childhood
memories hate to be a persistent Peter
persistent Peter is exactly what my
ex-wife called our monthly lovemaking
sessions Josie said you'd be working
this weekend well it can't be helped I
never can I see we are under the
marriage strain portion of our
children's entertainment now I have to
stay for work I never see and now we are
wallowing in parental neglect I have
never seen a more constipated movie in
my life I get that you're trying to set
up the conflict but it's been 20 minutes
just poo already do you think you could
read to me for a minute
the Victorian era signified the height
of the Industrial Revolution movie isn't
satisfied that you know what an
out-of-touch unfun person Christopher
Robin has become so it makes him read a
history book to his daughter like is
this the first time he's ever read to
her in his life dad I never knew you
could draw so well
oh come on movie there's a distinct
difference between gently tugging on my
heartstrings and trying desperately to
milk a dry cow stop tugging on me movie
I've got no milk jeez did the spirit
from hereditary just infest this house
why the hell is there an unopened jar of
damn honey on the table anyway the way
this is cut makes it seem like the whole
thing gets set into motion because of
some spilled honey woke up Pooh Bear
certainly plenty of people will spill
honey all over England and poo basically
wanders out of the Hundred Acre Wood
because he can't find anyone else to
talk to so what does the honey trap have
to do with anything
oh she was to Jim Cummings as a national
treasure frightening
whiny the Pooh who would be excellent at
cinemasins hello poos hello from the
other side moment conveniently takes
place at a park in London that is
somehow completely secluded
unoccupied and located directly across
the street from the robin's nest
what to do what to do what to do what to
do indeed this is the part of the movie
where it officially becomes Hook also
the guy who directed this to the movie
called Finding Neverland which was about
JM Barrie and how he was inspired to
write the story of Peter Pan the point
being this guy did Machine Gun Preacher
to poo that's rude
no stress distressed boom the movie
really does write some accidental jokes
for granted they aren't good jokes like
laughing at Imogen Poots name like I did
for an hour in church the other day
still it's difficult not to notice these
things in the dialogue and how immature
I but the tree I remember was behind the
cottage in Sussex not here in London I
suppose it's where it needs to be it's
where it needs to be is 100 Acre Wood
zis for reasons nosy neighbor knows not
that nervous neighbour is nearby
nevertheless nosy neighbor navigates
nimbly nearing nonsensically nervous
neighbour naturally we put all weekend
for Jean Rami this is the fourth time
this guy's brought up gin rummy in a
span of like 10 minutes his wife has
definitely run off with a Denzel
Washington look-alike by this point and
now Pooh is eating honey from the same
type of jar but it's unbroken is it a
new jar when did he clean up the mess of
the first job that stupid pointless
broken honey jar is going to haunt my
nightmares until Gabriel Byrne agrees to
throw it into the fire for me who is
completely stuck to this rug because his
feet have a bunch of honey on them but
Christopher is able to pull him off in
one motion without taking the rug with
it poo traipse through honey then had a
bunch on his feet and mouth but sure
honey is really easy to clean up on a
toy bear even if this is just
Christopher Robin's imagination I guess
I'm sending his imagination for the
continuity errors how does this lone jar
collapse all these shelves if you look
closely you can see it clearly falls in
front of them and it doesn't even make
contact and even if it did if one jar
falling a few feet can collapse your
entire shelving system I think that
clumsy asshole did you a favor can't see
moving and talking but why
seriously it didn't seem to bother
Londoners in those Paddington movies
make your mind English bear movies how
would you know that I mean yeah it's
definitely poo but just 10 seconds ago
you ran into this little girl with a
balloon and they were selling balloons
at the train station and this is clearly
a woman pushing a stroller with a
balloon on it but no clear poo so what
makes you so certain it's him look dude
if Hayley Atwell wasn't able to get a
message through to Christopher about
working too hard you're sure not who
curse differ values the advice of a
possibly imaginary bear over his
gorgeous white yeah we call this the man
mumbles math equations while his teddy
bear nods off to sleep on a train seeing
it killed at pitch meetings basically
got the entire movie Greenland well look
she's working does she have a briefcase
like you holy crap this message is
hammered in this thing look this movie
is very sweet you'd have to be an
irredeemable dick to be harsh or to cute
innocent bear like poop voiced again by
the great Jim Cummings but this movie is
like a hodgepodge of a ton of other
movies and now it can add a Christmas
carol to its checklist look up who here
I come look out poo here I come is which
of the following a the new slogan for X
lakhs P what Michael Bay says when
picking new projects see the name of my
grunge revival Mandy the title of my
plungers autobiography well the thing is
to do this systematically follow the
simple honeybee systematically sounds
nothing like simple honeybee I know part
of the joke is how simple poo is but who
here's mattock as honey at least give it
an effort boom terrifying elephant and
weasel like beasts who wonder the world
preying on happiness aren't real see
Christopher Robin gets me did you do let
me go I suppose I did is this movie
actually trying to depress me
we are almost an hour in and it's still
basically the children's version of
remains of the day oh you're right you
are a bear of very little brain you'd
have to be an irredeemable dick to be
harsh toward a cute innocent bear lake
Pooh voiced again by the great Jim
Cummings yes of course I've grown up I'm
- sure but at that depth you would have
to have been standing well above the
water even as a child so not sure what
growing up has to do with anything like
more than usual he's clean-shaven and
you can't see any other part of his body
dare you pretend to be Christopher Robin
he'd never size that dick good god the
section of the movie is so much like
Alice in Wonderland and I'm absolutely
positive that you and McGregor is gonna
start Futterwacken describes good
describes
Christopher
it's you while the name Christopher
Robin has been said many times in this
movie already now that he's playing
again and doesn't care about his luggage
company anymore can this be the roll
pick with moment
this goes on for some time that's hella
pissed
owls eyeball looking through a tree
Trump makes me think this is subliminal
advertising for Disney's 2000 animated
movie dinosaur which son Kyle made 349
million worldwide and everybody forgot
about as soon as they left the theater
anyway a dinosaur too will soon be
hypnotizing audiences into paying money
that they forgot they forked over in the
summer of 2025 a few months after the
live-action Oliver and company well I am
a bear of very little brain no poo you
are I think a bear of very big heart
backhanded compliments and someone do a
geography check on the Hundred Acre Wood
100 acres isn't even two-tenths of a
square mile and there seems to be a lot
of space here Plus isn't all of this in
some sort of magic tree in England that
somehow bigger on the inside wait is it
a tree TARDIS is it his treatise is what
are your Time Lord is it more
importantly no case of important thanks
odd is naive woodland creatures have so
much accidental wisdom this is work more
important than your daughter theme is a
dead horse that's been beaten so much
that it's really just a big crater in
the ground anything resembling a horse
is long gone this moment is brought to
you by the book noses and things that
are directly on them goodbye Christopher
no goodbye Christopher Robin is a
different live-action Winnie the Pooh
movie about the actual Christopher Robin
and somehow that came out within one
year of this one it's the Deep Impact
Armageddon of our time only this time
Armageddon is titled really deep impact
for maximum confusion Christopher tries
to run to wherever he's going before his
wife and daughter see him and his
daughter of course opens the window at
the exact worst time they use X
disappointed looks like someone just saw
Citizen Kane well I needed to make room
in its briefcase for the real important
stuff seeing us how high-strung see rob
has been so far even after his fun time
with the poo gang is there any way he
didn't check his briefcase to make sure
all his papers were in there before he
left
she cow woman mr. G's Christopher what
you do with your private time is
completely up to you keep that stuff to
yourself oh goody Madeleine's found a
way to make tennis matches last ten
times longer than normal is it all tied
up nice and tight well of course I used
a Tigger not you hundred acres of great
balloon make you happy oh yes it's a
beautiful 1956 French film that won the
Best Original Screenplay Oscar wait a
minute 1956 I couldn't even seen that
movie yet duh this girl who by all
measures is a ridiculously smart nerd
book or and spells expedition as
expedition because the imaginary stuffed
animals who really exist pronounce it
that way it's going to be no fun like
this at boarding school page or in this
movie apparently if Mycroft Holmes was
playing golf all weekend instead of
working like he said he was and why did
he bring the clubs with him to work why
didn't he drop them off at his house I
guess somehow Christopher needs to know
that his boss wasn't where he said he
was so that he can finally quit his job
to support his family wait
also couldn t be playing after the
meeting why would sobbing Robin
automatically assume he's been shirking
his duties
welcome to okay so the animals have some
funny mispronunciation of London
separating it into two distinct words
but earlier pooh told piglet do you see
all I'm asking is movie have some
consistency with your errors reflections
do occur in nature right they do have
Stillwater occasionally in the whoop
don't think thank just thank you thank
you porpoise how is orifice any easier
to say or more known a word than officer
who knows the word orifice and not
officer I suddenly have a lot more
questions about the things that go on
with this Hundred Acre Wood convenient
Winslow truck is convenient I can't
decide which is more unlikely but the
suitcase would remain upright that no
one would have flagged this vehicle down
yet or that this rope would somehow be
this securely tied on both ends so since
I mean down let's go with all three
London's a big city right like a really
big city I mean the odds of these
stuffed animals landing exactly on this
windshield and have to be 100 billion to
1 Winslow I know Christopher Robin
speaks poo and Friends why is it so easy
to derive Winslow's from little words
these papers in this open box after
traveling behind this vehicle for this
far is the very definition of something
that just can't even
hello talking donkey how are you doing
today this greeting really only works in
this very specific situation for what
it's worth from experience
oh no my father's love also I understand
papers getting scattered maybe blowing
around on the ground and otherwise being
out of reach but this is Harry Potter
levels of magic flying paper also also
considering how much this movies pounded
the relative unimportance of these
papers it's kind of hard to feel bad or
worried about them this is not like
Michael Douglas his stupid book and
Wonder Boys here where the book has been
set up as something truly important but
I'd remove a hundred sins right now if
Robert Downey jr. showed up trying to
retrieve the papers as they fly around
your safe that's all that's important
not my papers I'm glad we have reached
the moral of the story portion of the
film because it means it might finally
end I do have to say both things can be
important just because one thing is more
important than the other doesn't mean
the papers have to be meaningless and
I'll read you a bedtime story every
night ha ha ha but haven't we all learn
lessons about having fun at this point
he wasn't going to be reading her
history books after his life-changing
experience was he darling you're a
genius
looks like Christopher Robin went to the
Jeff Goldblum in Independence Day school
of giving a genius credit to people who
an oculus Li say stuff unrelated to the
problem that makes them figure out the
problem they have a tough time fitting
all that on the sign but they are a
grade-school how was this meeting still
going on if they've already fired the
team today stop the meeting in the
middle to fire them and then tell them
to pack up and then reconvene Ian sigh
mean reconvene the meeting Christopher
Robin tells the executives at a luggage
company to lower their prices so the
common man can afford their products and
that they can earn more money and thank
God Christopher works at a high-end
luggage company because the same idea
wouldn't work at a financially troubled
company that already sold to the
working-class tips let's address the
Heffalump in the Rouge considering he
just heard the word have a long how does
he know it's an elephant like creature I
told you I was looking if this guy ever
commits a murder he'll be carrying the
body up in an elevator with several
witnesses and leave the murder weapon in
his coat pocket am i comparing a day of
golf with a serious crime of murder yes
yes I am when you do nothing it leads to
the very best of something we've now hit
the part of the picture where the
characters are just okay with everything
because the movie needs to end to think
that this stuffy businessman is this
open to Christopher's unpreparedness
leaving midway through the meeting
talking about to nonsense about
Heffalumps and Woozles and coming back
with an idea to change the entire
philosophy of the company is laughable
but I'll go along with it if it gets me
to the credits also go ahead and stay
home and try using this logic on your
boss tomorrow see how it goes for you
also this philosophy would explain why
in the movie truly feels like a whole
bunch of nothing did
get that right close enough close enough
basically word-for-word how you said it
when you came in that's impressive
I mean I'm literally a professional knit
picker and even I'd have let that one
slide do sir are a true artist get it
because he's like the real life of your
and he's owl and he's rabid and she's
kanga or something my point is if you're
going to introduce us to the idea that
these winslow workers are human
counterparts to the animals at least
give them enough screentime for us to
figure out who is who
enabling Christopher Robin what day is
it
flush honey badger don't care honey
badger don't get it it just takes what
it wants as you might have heard we
recently announced the inaugural year of
sin week it's coming up soon polish sin
week is an e convention that you can
access at all levels of patreon it will
have five cinemasins videos that week
for members panels a live podcast and
much more and if you're signed up at the
top tier you're eligible to attend sin
week in-person hang out with Chris
Jeremy and the sentence gang in
beautiful Nashville Tennessee we'll be
digging up a top go you'll even be
treated to some great food if you
haven't already sign up today at
patreon.com slash cinemasins
join the club we it's rum worth one good
lands like we believed it once make us
believe it again do you think you could
read to me for a minute being Scottish
with a little Oh most wretched miserable
servile pathetic trust remember me I'm
your wife turn matter H I'm your wife
but after what you just said I'm not
even sure I want to be dead anymore you
never had it so good
[Music]